so the scene where anakin goes to the  jedi temple to wipe out the young lands  was actually improvised now i don't mean  the scene of him slaying younglings was  improvised but a little startle that the  young man does here where he takes a  step back that was improvised and not a  direction given by george lucas so this  information was revealed by the actor  that played a young man here ross  speedman and what happened was as anakin  hayden christensen pulled out his  lightsaber to ignite it he actually  screamed boo which obviously the kid  didn't see this coming so then he was a  little shocked by hearing it i just find  it kind of funny because now i imagine  anakin in this scene screaming but the  younglings before he slays them is this  canon let me know in the comment section  below